Imagine you go for a hike and come across a cabin.
It looks interesting, so you decide to explore.
But as you grow closer, you notice something strange.
You hear the sound of your favorite song in the background.
When you open the door, you see shoes and a jacket fitted perfectly for you.
On the table, you see the books and magazines you like to read.
In
the refrigerator, you notice your favorite snacks.
And
in the bathroom, you find all the toiletries you normally use.
Everything you need to survive, tailored just to your liking, is there.
How
did the cabin get arranged so precisely as it is?
Maybe you just got lucky, and all of this is a matter of coincidence.
But that doesn't seem very reasonable if you think about it for a minute, does it?
I mean, there's just too many things tailored precisely for you.
You might not know why, or you might not know who did it, but clearly there's some
purpose and design behind the arrangement of this cabin.
Freeman J. Dyson, a renowned theoretical physicist, once said, As we look out
into the universe and identify the many accidents of physics and astronomy that have
worked to our benefit, it almost seems as if the universe must in some sense have
known that we were coming. The laws of physics and astronomy
all exist within a very small range, to allow the universe to support
life. It's as if these laws exist on a razor's edge, and the slightest change
to the left or the right, and the entire universe becomes inhospitable to life.
When I was in college, some friends of mine lived on the third story of an apartment
building with a window, overlooking a parking lot, tall row of trees, a big water
gutter, and then a stop sign. And they thought it'd be
entertaining and funny to open up their window, use one of those huge water balloon
launchers, and launch balloons to try to hit cars as they came home.
Well, one evening we were sitting there, and we launched one from the window.
It cleared the water gutter, the trees, the parking lot, and hit a car right on the
windshield, and cracked it. And yes, we had to pay for it.
Imagine how many factors we had to get right to hit our target.
For example, what if there was more water in the balloon?
We wouldn't have gone far enough.
What if there was less water? We would have gone too far.
What if we were up in the mountains where there's different air pressure?
We would have gone further. What if the tension in the launcher was different?
There's all these things we had to get right to hit our target.
Well, that's not too different from our universe as a whole.
You see, the universe has been expanding at a very carefully and calibrated rate
since its inception. But if that rate were different, in comparison with the mass
density, or with the dark energy, then we couldn't even have a universe that's
capable of supporting life. So what are the mathematical odds that a
universe, with its laws of physics and cosmology randomly generated, being
capable of having stars which are necessary for there to be life?
Well, according to astrophysicist Lee Smolin, the odds are 1 times 10 to the 229th
power. You realize how big of a number that is?
That's one, with 229 zeros after it.
Essentially, that's equivalent to taking every single proton in the entire universe.
And each of those protons would represent its own universe with laws of physics
randomly generated. Mathematically speaking, if that were the case, none of these
universes would be capable of generating stars, which means it wouldn't be capable
of having life. But let's compare this to our cabin.
What if you were blindfolded in this cabin and you were trying to find a lost coin?
What are the odds that you could find it?
Well, what if we expanded it to the city that I'm in?
Or to the country? Or to the entire planet?
Or how about our solar system? What about our galaxy?
What if we expanded it to the entire universe?
What are the mathematical odds that blindfolded you could find this coin?
Do you realize that it is far more likely, far more likely, you would find this coin
than we would find ourselves in a universe with randomly generated laws capable
of supporting complex life? There is very little debate that our universe is
exquisitely fine-tuned. The question is, what best explains the fine-tuning?
One option people often say is chance, but I think we've seen clearly
mathematically that this is not a reasonable explanation.
Another option people say is law.
Maybe there's some law that requires the other laws to be fine-tuned for life.
But the problem is, is that laws in physics and cosmology tend to create things that
are simple and repeatable, not complex and specified like we see in the laws that
govern our universe. One final option often used to explain away fine-tuning is
called the multiverse, which is the idea that either there's a ton of universes out
there, or an infinite number of universes.
Therefore, we shouldn't be surprised that we happen to find ourselves in a universe
fine-tuned for life. Well, there's a couple problems with appealing to this to
explain away fine-tuning. One problem is that there's no direct scientific evidence
for the multiverse. At this stage, it's scientific conjecture.
But even if we do find evidence for the multiverse, this wouldn't explain away
design. In fact, all it would do is move design away from this universe to the
multiverse. There would still need to be an explanation for why there is a
multiverse that generates individually fine-tuned universes.
So think about it this way. If we're trying to explain away design of a car, and
somebody says, oh, we can explain away by a factory, you'd say, wait a minute.
There still needs to be a sufficient explanation for the factory.
Rather than law, chance, or the multiverse explaining away fine-tuning, I
think the best explanation is that there is a fine-tuner who organized the universe
with us in mind. Just as the arrangement of the cabin pointed towards somebody
expecting our arrival, the exquisite fine-tuning of life best
points towards someone expecting us to live here and even to feel at home.